we're in the last days of President
Obama's second term and I know that many
won't ever recognize this but things are
actually pretty good under President
Obama we know that many Trump supporters
will never accept it or recognize it
they're in an alternate reality I told
you earlier this week about a PPP poll
which exposed that 39% of Trump
supporters think that the stock market
is down under Obama although it's more
than doubled two-thirds of Trump
supporters believe that unemployment is
up under Obama although it's been
reduced by nearly 50% 40% of Trump
supporters believe that Donald Trump won
the popular vote another poll says that
as high as 52% of Trump supporters
believe Trump won the popular vote they
actually lost the popular vote by nearly
three million votes to Hillary Clinton
60% of Trump supporters believe that
millions of people voted illegally for
Hillary Clinton and nearly
three-quarters of Trump supporters
believe that George Soros paid people to
protest Donald Trump events that of
course is a fake news story that has
been debunked but by and large the
recent Gallup poll shows that most
Americans realize it's been pretty good
under President Obama President Obama's
approval rating as he is getting ready
to leave office is at 57 percent that is
35 percentage points higher than george
w bush's approval rating was as he was
on his way out
this Gallup poll is not an outlier
there's a Rasmussen Reports survey and a
Reuters Ipsos survey which also are very
close at 54 and 56 percent approval to
the 57 percent number touted by Gallup
this makes sense to me if you're just
looking at indicators we've seen a huge
reduction in unemployment under
President Obama we've seen a record job
creation streak under President Obama
inflation is totally under control the
stock market has more than doubled and
delusional trumpets aside we have the
fewest Americans without health
insurance for a very long time poverty
is down now this doesn't mean that
everything is great for everyone if you
personally are in poverty can't afford
health insurance
can't afford food have no job you're not
better off necessarily but we have to
talk about the big picture and what
types of policies help the largest
number of people let's see and evaluate
what happens under Donald Trump
we have indicators that we can look at
when Donald Trump's takes over what will
happen to wages what will happen to
unemployment what will happen to the
stock market what will happen to income
inequality what will happen to the
portion of Americans that have no health
insurance
we have measurable data that we can
compare and contrast when we compare
President Obama to George W Bush on the
numbers there is no comparison I mean
we're talking about orders of magnitude
better under President Obama than under
george w bush it is mathematically
undeniable period the only way you can
come away with a different conclusion is
with distraction conspiracy theories
like the so-called labor force
conspiracy theory that has been a
favorite of donald trump and many of his
surrogates and many of the trumpet
supporters have fallen for it as well
and i the reason i'm talking about this
today is very often we have a transition
of power and all of a sudden we forget
to say hey let's just look at the
indicators it's very easy to say i don't
like the president so things are bad or
i like the president then things are
good we have data we can look at we have
lots of data and I know that the
trumpets number one who are committed to
Obama having been a disaster will
explain away the data in some way I know
that the trumpets that are committed to
the idea that Trump will make America
great again will say that that's what
Trump has done once he takes office
regardless of what the numbers are but
as rational thinkers as individuals who
want to be able to say hey here's the
data let's not forget as we start to get
distance from presidents about what
those numbers actually tell us it's very
easy to have a general sense of what
happened yeah I remember that there was
that recession under Bush but it's been
a while I don't think things were
under bush or yeah there was that that
job-creation streak under obama but it
wasn't a particularly strong economy
let's keep a close eye on the metrics
under Donald Trump as compared to the
prior two presidents and that way we can
make a fact-based analysis of how things
are going is Trump making America great
again
or will Trump be taking America down
from what was clearly a very strong
eight-year run economically under
President Obama when you look at the
YouTube comments for this story you're
going to see the Trump is denying that
this is a reality it's gonna be real
tough to deal with them during the Trump
administration they are committed
emotionally and psychologically to Trump
fixed everything Obama ruined everything
even if the numbers don't end up showing
that I'm open to seeing Trump continues
to reduce unemployment
if consumer confidence increases under
Donald Trump if we start seeing a
favorable wage data under Donald Trump
I'll be the first to say I don't like
the guy because of the things he's said
and done but he improved the economy if
that's not what happens though I'm going
to absolutely be critical of him and
it's gonna be a fact-based analysis
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one
remember we're raising money to expand
the David Pakman show big league as well
as expand progressive activism go to
david pakman.com slash donate donations
of any size are much appreciated